[Music]
bismillah I'm doing a lot peace be with
you you turn it into the D show every
week at hamdulillah we're here to help
enlighten you because knowledge is key
knowledge you got to have knowledge and
when you have that proper knowledge you
see that you now is developed a
certainty in Islam you know that Islam
is indeed from the Creator it's not a
organized religion by man or men but it
was sent down organized by the Creator
who created man and woman and everything
in this universe the one creator Allah
now let me tell you this now you're
probably wondering look I've accepted
Islam I agree with some my very nature
that I'm not gonna worship anything in
creation but the Creator and everybody
say a lot Muhammad is the last final
messenger and this would obviously
include Jesus Moses and all the
preceding messengers I'm gonna pray five
times a day minimum I'm gonna do the
five pillars without a doubt why am I
going through these hardships tell tell
me Eddie
why I lost you know my job I'm having
problems tough times I'm a Muslim and
I'm going through all these troubles and
hard times explain that to me and that's
what we're gonna be talking about in
this week's show so it's very exciting
it's a very exciting show and hopefully
at the end you have a different
perspective with my next guest surprised
when you come back here on the decodable
anyway
[Music]
this is the how are you I'm Billa people
can go and visit your own section at the
Dean show calm you're known for the
program that we did unhappy how to be
happy we discussed that and that's I
didn't show calm this week here on the
Dean show we're gonna be talking about
also another very important topic and
that's what we know for is really
important issues clearing it from the
minds of people who have doubt about it
hopefully God willing making it really
crystal clear to end good and evil many
people they say okay look if there's a
there's a God specifically we were
talking about someone comes into Islam
and now they're going upon hardship upon
hardship another person says if there's
a God why is there so much evil in the
world how do we tackle this so any the
whole concept of trials tribulation test
from Allah Spano atala how does it
really work if actually believe that
allah subhanho wa taala why did this
happen I truly believe that every Muslim
should know this basic knowledge before
even moving any further into the Dean as
this is something that everybody faces
no one of us not a single person of us
except that they will face hardship
isn't that right yes Allah says in the
Quran Leah blue welcome I Iike master
nomina Allah will test you to know who
has the most sincere and correct actions
life was never meant to be comfortable
life was full of hardships life
sometimes it caused your life life
sometimes will cause you to bleed to cry
and be sad and so on but the end this is
just a test for most of hano attire
so I'll mention two reasons why does
Allah support us and as these tests oh
please give me your undivided attention
and all those who are watching why would
Allah Subhan Allah allow us to go to
testing
tribulation hardship etc number one
Allah does so to distinguish the
truthful from the liar
simple test for the true colors to
appear when someone goes through
hardship don't you agree with me
yes so someone at one time I was in the
Masjid and this is a true story right
before I share prayer I was walking I
accidentally stepped on someone's white
puma shoes mm-hmm he got so upset he's
like you stepped on my new white puma
shoes you know what I'm not gonna pray
anymore so whenever testing happened
it's a test from Allah he literally said
I'm not cuz you stepped on oh he white
yes he left I'm not praying anymore he's
only heard himself now absolutely so
that test came to show the truthful from
the liar she so the one who is strong a
man from the weekiy men etc etc Allah
said what's your proof brother Allah
says no Quran Alif LAAM Meem three
letters that no one really knows the
meaning some scholars given meaning to
it but that mean that we follow them
perhaps the majority is that I live
letter Lam a letter me my mother then
Allah says has he been a so and neuter
aku and your pool a man no home the
afternoon do the people think that they
all say I believe and they will not be
tested you think is at that simple to go
to Jannah and ultimate happiness and
Jenna where allow us tell you I am
pleased by you where you will enjoy all
these bricks of gold and silver which
your house is made out of this and you
enjoy your spouse in Jannah and the mall
which you visit every Friday and the
breeze that will come to you making more
and more handsome and beautiful and most
joyful thing in the whole existence of
human being is the moment they see Allah
subhana WA Ta'ala all that just like
that without no testing we never argued
the driver's license test we never
argued that drug test from a corporation
so number one is a lot tested show the
truthful from the liar true colors up
here the second reason some people would
ask what do you think Eddie we never
planned this out by the way I don't ask
you a question what do you think will be
the follow-up question to this so a lot
came to test us ok what would some
people ask afterwards what do you think
please tell me
doesn't a lot already know yes I said
that's a good point yes it doesn't a lot
really know the truthful from the liar
and that's a very valid question as long
as asked with respect and so on yes a
lot of panels and the second reason
Allah says in the Quran clearly well
and if we were to torture punish those
who we've never sent a prophet to know
Dean show video that tells us about
Islam there is no doubt why there's no
convening of the message and we punish
them before that message was transferred
to them they would have said why he
punished us
Lola or Santa Elena rasullah shouldn't
you Allah first test us send us a
prophet and they would have never failed
would have been protected so a lot of
the second reason Allah test us pay
attention so Allah can judge me and you
and all the viewers according to our
actions and sayings and not according to
Allah previous knowledge about us so I
wanted I was a teacher as I'm in school
which is sometimes one of the most paid
job ever but was beautiful hundred
there's nothing more beautiful Eddie
then quality boat saucepan I want that
the highest noble most noble job ever
even call people to Allah I'm gonna in
my profession I do it full-time but
above that City a doctor but above all
is those who column woman a sign of
called Allah says who's better I'm an
economy man dial OS got to make me and
you and all those that would share this
video amongst them I mean I mean are
proud of me so I was a teacher in Sunday
school
and I can predict people's marks and
maybe we will give me a teacher you
might live that example with me so I
would say you know what Sarah
you most likely to get this mark you
know what I've met you'll get that mark
so can I give people an F without
testing them what would happen
afterwards what you think nobody here
I'm sure because that's not fair test me
give me that exam you kept probably with
my report card
so once I give him the test lo and
behold they got the same exact marks I
predicted now that I know the unseen but
just an educated guess so number two
Allah would test us so we are judged by
our actions and sayings and not about a
lot about us is that clear so now when
you go you're more clear my day of
judgment Allah will not hear from us
well you know what or you never tested
me we were all tested so you know go
there you don't go there and complain
you didn't test me I sent messages to
you Allah has given you all these Dawa
YouTube videos allows you know all these
avenues it might be through a path with
whatever it may be so he cut the chase
no more arguing that's what everyone was
what to show the true colors the truth
from the liar
number two so Allah can judge
point your actions and sayings and not
according to allows previous knowledge
about you so these were the two core
reasons why Allah allowed us to go
through hardship and pay attention a lot
of tested tests you according to your
level of Deen and Iman how about I will
go on deeper into that because it's very
important after their break yeah let's
do the house bed we're gonna go deeper
into that question talking about
hardships why are you experiencing them
all this and more we have the answers in
Islam and we come back here indicia what
are you gonna do with it if somebody's
been trying to deliver something to you
like we've been trying to deliver the
truth that there's only one God that you
worship Him alone not his creation
welcome to the bee show one of the most
exciting purpose of life talk shows in
the world since 2006 that the show has
been working on clearing up the many
faults misconceptions about Islam and
Muslims and at the same time delivering
the simple message of the purpose of
life in a fun and exciting way I was at
a restaurant I was dressed like this and
a woman came to me she said are you a
rabbi we want you to develop a better
understanding about the pure Islam and
the real message that it teaches peace
submission surrender uh no B D install
mighty God mankind that's why we're
sharing this message because we want the
best for you and we want the best for
all mankind
we'll see you next time God willing on
today's show continue to tune in peace
be on to you please subscribe to the D
show follow us on our official Facebook
and Twitter pages in the links below
please also help support the D show by
making a donation in the link below back
here on the D show and we're talking
about hardships continue on you want to
elaborate on a certain point yes so the
level of hardships so note that there
are brothers and sisters in Syria being
killed there are sisters being raped
there are people all around the world
whatever Muslim country number some
country are believing in brothers and
sisters who go through hardship that
hardship is of levels how does it work
around well so like Salah law and he was
send us has an authentic hadith
remembrance of Allah do a side note is
that a man came and asked him yet also
Allah
men I should do Nesi by that who are the
people who are tested the most I was
asked that question by the way when I
was younger about grade 9 or so and I
was thinking the answer to b4
Ferro cause fear was so evil he deserves
that worst of hardships the prophets
answer was what l-anbiya
meaning the prophets are tested the most
then he says to must lied to hone in the
righteous somebody I'm finna fan Anthony
so it keeps going down so the prophets
are tested the most he want a proof of
this muhammad sallallaahu was seldom one
time his wife Aisha was complaining
about a headache so the prophets she
said what sir
well my head the probably said no
actually my I have a bad headache then
he says every pain of Prophet goes
through my pain is double the pain of
any other human being they were tested
the most then he goes down the level and
I love that next part and the promise
our sign says you tell Malik Audra Dini
you'll be tested according to your
commitment to your religion so in
Kenneth's edenia saliva if your
commitment your reason was strong what
will happen to the testing I'll go up it
will increase no no break go even to the
next level Z de favela when kennefa Dini
Erica if they were a softie the white
puma shoes step on and they leave the
message it what will happen to the test
afterwards hopefully I don't be taken
lightly on that person you'll not go to
the next level so now when people are
tested more and more rather this shows
that level of a man they may have that's
one of the signs now one of the signs to
show how much a man they may have and
only Allah knows exactly but the other
side is how much hard should we go
through so with this being said this is
the commitment to your Dean some people
brother lovely very frank don't see that
and Allah is al Hakim they always Allah
knows was behind that while Allah knows
who's behind that camera and all what we
see is just this much I'll give you an
example but a sister emailed me this
true story yeah and then she sends in an
email right away on a commit suicide dr.
de Y and one commits suicide your last
wish I'm gonna communicate with etc then
I replied back during my lunch time at
work then I'd say you know I wanna play
suicide what's the deal
she says this email she says I liked
this guy when I was 15 years old I loved
him more than anything in the world
loved him for six seven years she's 21
years old and she I kept making dua to
Allah to pound a day and night Ya Allah
please give me that man you a lot please
give me that man and guess what happened
this man got engaged to someone else she
said I want to commit suicide I felt so
depressed etc etc etc why that hardship
why why why cause she didn't get the man
of what she perceived was a man of her
dreams
yes this is the man I want this man
looks good
amazing I made dua why am I gonna have
my block was what guess what happened
afterwards she says will love me with
this
she says alhamdulillah brother the
brother did not get engaged to me and
ham didn't love hamdulillah why so this
is some time later now yes
some time after after the brother got
engaged there's some time later she says
that brother was found in the club mmm
that brother was found drinking alcohol
Allah did not make that man get married
to me so he ended up possibly being an
adulterer now yet fornicating and
cheating on his wife absolutely so this
would have been her now yes she's
thankful so guys so now it was a
blessing yes but the question is did you
have to see the effects to be thankful
why you got to go through that now to
see ya CD now you appreciate like I'd
rather go through hardship than marrying
him and go through that torture so I'll
give you a present actually absolutely
yes absolutely so almost and tests you
yeah raise your ranks and then to go to
the next level Allah would wipe away
your sins mm-hmm some people say okay
Allah tests me about that I heard your
your your roles so number one about the
testing the true colors okay I got that
then the next one when Allah tests you
and the hardship that you go through
your sins are being dropped
you're being nice and clean because
agenda pair that is sin free can't go to
Jenny whatever one single sin you gotta
be clean yeah
so sometimes we don't do enough worship
Eddie we don't worship Allah enough
we're not as sincere enough and Allah
wants you not to go through prepare
hellfire doesn't why you get to watch it
and in the grave so I'm like gives you
these hardships to purify you like a tab
so I'm not doesn't not lun never intends
to harm you
never Allah never hates you Allah loves
you and I'm not loves you by you going
to these hardships a parent a father
relates wisdom to himself by saying I'm
gonna give one son $20 the other side
$10 and you'd say Baba that's not fair
that's not fair but the father says I
know the one want to give twenty will
know how to spend it don't know how I
gave ten doesn't know how to spend it
we should relate wisdom to Allah and
hacking to always he knows who to give
some people Eddie are poor because
that's the only way for him to go to
paradise yeah some people Allah made
them rich because that's the only way
for him to go to paradise otherwise I
would not work out for them Ya Allah
just gives and takes and all these
hardships for a reason I lost pride when
all these deeds are being wiped away and
cleaned every thorn that hits you and
picks you sins will be falling off every
paint until the Sun rises and says
then she LD walk on earth that are
having a single sin on you
Ya Allah when I open the show of when we
first started there's this common
statement that if there is a God then
why is there so much evil in the world
how would you address this so if you
know that if you notice through our talk
we can use some of the content by saying
that person perceived it to be evil
perceived it to be bad just like that
girl just like that sister and you want
you know what the sister said afterwards
I didn't finish the story for you to
continue that example now she liked
another guy so much and she says this
guy is so religious so practicing and
she said I may go out to Allah all day
and all night
but wallahi if Allah doesn't bless this
man to me as a husband I'm gonna commit
suicide again again what's wrong with
you Allah showed it to you so you don't
perceive it as Allah as evil we seek
Allah's refuge you never attributed
attributes Toscana wa'ta'ala it's very
important Allah is good allah subhanho
wa taala his mercy is by default his
merciful by default he said Rometty my
mercy sever cut radha be my mercy
overcame my anger when Allah by default
is so merciful
so I'm also parent Allah just to show
Allah is mercy and I was not about evil
Rasul Allah Allah Allah said I must
express how much Allah is and Eddie just
just imagine this before we even were
created before we you came to life
before I came to life our Father Adam
alayhi Salam was made and shaped and
there was no soul blown into Adam yet it
softening hadith that it says Adam and I
still am the soul Allah blew the soul
and to add them what ruh-roh has the
soul reached the head what happened to
either a Sarah he sneezed
then otherwise time when he sneezed and
I will into life he said alhamdulillah
now pay attention the first word the
Creator will ever say to the creation
the first word the human being will ever
hear from the Creator what is it it
hammock Allah may my mercy be upon you
may Allah's mercy be upon him if this is
the beginning in West and yes Allah
Akbar look at the end really quick Rasul
Allah is Allah honey what's Adam says
the Allah has how many mercies a hundred
mercies a hundred parts and he allowed
only one to descend on earth from that
mercy every single one of us has mercy
towards the other when we go and give
someone water when we go help our
parents when we go
pick up something from the ground the at
mercy between the animals to that extent
all that mercy is from what from that
one single merciful loss penomet Allah
the Prophet says what yo more clear my
day of judgment that mercy shall be
joined with the rest of the 99 Allah
Akbar
can extend the mercial be spread all
over the place there's a hadith that has
some slight weakness to it Shaitaan the
devil Iblees who knows he's destroyed
and he is the evil one it believes is
the evil one he sees all that mercy only
of judgment the one mercy came by with
the rest of the 99 he says walking what
about me you know I think I can make it
for how merciful Allah is on that day
but at least Shaitaan will never
obviously go there but they're pointing
Alliance by default very merciful and we
do not attribute evil to a lost pan over
time we're gonna take a break sure and
we'll be right back with more on this
very important topic here on the d show
please subscribe to the dgo follow us on
our official Facebook and Twitter pages
in the links below
please also help support the V show by
making a donation in the link below back
here on the D show and we're talking
about and giving some advice and and
looking at the wisdom so how should a
people when a calamity hits a hardship
hits and now as I open the show I said
look this person just accepted what's in
their very nature there's nothing worthy
of worship except the crater I'm not
gonna worship anything but the one who
created me the one I'm gonna go back to
my Maker
that's why I worship and I'm gonna
follow the last funnel message that was
sent to mankind apart Muhammad peace be
upon him we got the blueprint the Quran
and Sunnah now person is doing you know
the acts of worship and now a hardship
upon hardship and should they be excited
about the relief coming because doesn't
Allah say look that finding a milos to
do so that where every difficulty comes
ease so do they just hold down a little
bit longer and not give up because what
happens if you give up and what happens
if you hold on absolutely so the
calamity hits you right away what's the
first thing the first thing you call
nine-one-one yes but our 9-1-1 is a lot
spent over here before you call 9-1-1
remember that a las ponte is there for
you so the first thing is you be patient
and they're very nice statement now the
Prophet teaches me and knew to say in
the language or the calamity falls to
Allah we belong and to Allah we shall
return there's one of the things that we
say remember these statements and the
very important is to be
the Prophet said a Sabra in the
submitted meaning the true patients are
to those who are patient the moment the
calamity hits upon them example there
was a lady in the graveyard
yeah and in the problem says you know
what take it easy hold on etc
don't exaggerate and so on the lady said
you don't know what I went through but
she does not know it was who Prophet
Muhammad SAW said so when she was with
the Prophet left
wise man I won't go into argument and he
walked by then the people told the lady
you know what that was a prophet
Muhammad SAW said me spoke to it she
felt so bad then she went to him and the
Prophet said a sober patients true
patients as the moment the calamity hits
upon you now you kind of recovered but
you won't get the full reward of that
test so I loved you through our heart to
do in that reward of hardships since
being wiped away from you elevate your
status in paradise you gotta be patient
in the beginning and know that Allah
subhana WA Ta'ala brother Eddie nothing
is coincidence in Islam there's no
something all by mistake in kulla
shay'in her luck now be cut that
everything was perfectly done everything
is decreed upon well this thing happened
here my marriage here this is that a
lost pound decreed all this to happen
and we should trust Allah subhana WA
Ta'ala there was a story where some
lights of Allah I was seldom told abou
cinema and I would say them and learned
that statement which is very profound
and a statement says whenever calamity
falls upon you Allah tells me in you to
say in the delay in aiding about your
own Allah Jordan if he mostly but he
were actively Hiram in her three
statements to Allah we belong and to
Allah we shall return number two or a
lot reward me for the hardship we want
the reward and number three is give me
something better a substitute that is
better than what I lost someone lost a
child someone lost this and that this
guess what happened almost animal when
she heard that from Abu Salam and her
husband weep when he told the hadith
she's ok I'll say whatever comes he
falls upon me guess what happened abuzer
my dice almost said Emma says when my
husband my beloved with my sweetheart
and those that know the CLR the
prophet's life and biography they know
that i was a man almost l had the most
beautiful love story on the Sahaba
when her husband died she remembered
what that statement her husband taught
her so she said ok
indeed Allah he went there they have
adjourned to Allah we belong and to
Allah we shall return Allah journey
famously Betty all are we worried for
the calamity the last part was
what give me a better substitute then
she says who in the world can be better
abou Solana who in the world can be
better at Manomet she was struggling
then she said you know what I trusted
Allah there's something good behind this
ah
it's difficult she said okay well uh
Cliff Lee I mean I know Allah give me
something better not too long after that
someone knocked at her door and man he's
a guest he's like I came on behalf of my
mother
what's the deal he wants to propose to
you Allahu Akbar
he wants to propose to you Oh mr. lemma
Oh Miss Emma cried she says Allah Akbar
the one who fulfilled that promise and
give me someone who is better than
Muhammad SAW said Allah so no there's a
wisdom behind it and you might not see
it and you might die without even seeing
it but definitely the good ending is it
in the afterlife will we realize things
let me touch something about drive you
don't mind sometimes you make da da da
ya Lana this hardship you I love this
hardship is falling upon me Allah help
me from it and a lot continues to put
you in that state of hardship and you
just don't understand what's going on
allah subhanho wa taala whenever you
make drought what are three things
happen number one a lot would lift the
heart for me for example okay Allah will
move that calamity away from me or Allah
will give you whatever he asked for
number to Allah for a wisdom what she
knows about he will not fulfill the
request that you had to him rather he
will move away some another calamity
does about to smash you yes
so remember that dry he made in great 10
when he had the crush towards that girl
he said y'all want to get me get me
married to her
remember that time I did not give it to
you because for a wisdom that Allah
knows best
so 10 years later Allah saved you from a
calamity because of that door ten years
ago so number two Allah would lift the
Hajj away from you number three is Allah
Samantha will save your rewards to Jenna
because that's where you the most on
your Maruyama
but there Eddie the only currency
exchange it's a select and say yeah yes
billions and dollars and loonies which
is Canadian dollars yen pounds are
useless Eddie nothing meaning means
nothing the only currency exchange is
the hasson at the good deeds and i say
at the bad deeds so on that day your job
these hardships will be put on the skin
and will clear when the judgment with
elevates your status and your so
thankful to allah that allah has given
this all to you imagine just imagine
that
with me I love we know as Muslims
there's me Zen which is a scale the
Allah will steal your good deeds right
and the bad deeds etc imagine you go
there you see your bad deeds outweigh
your good deeds how'd the press with the
person feel there's no way out of this
all that sadness all that depression all
of a sudden you see maximized the good
deeds coming on the scale that is all
the bad deeds are gone they worked away
they're vanished why because of the
hardships that you faced because of the
diet that you made and I'll never give
it to you the day needed the most was
that day so then you become think of
whatever you went through there's
something to comprehend whenever Allah
allows you to go through a hardship
there is good behind it for the
believers num there's a lot of good
behind it just be patient
go back to Allah subhana WA Ta'ala as
you mentioned that in the beginning of
your talk knowledge is key knowledge is
key because without knowledge without
the best most heart out how can people
realize to be patient you have to know
there's a reward behind all of this
there's a reward behind all this be
patient has a nice plan for you they
just didn't understand something before
we cut out we're almost out of time it
reminds me of a beautiful hadith and
this is the blessings of of having this
knowledge that you can fall back it's an
anchor point now a reference point you
can go back to and you can remember
these hadith these examples and it helps
to motivate you to stay with it one that
comes to my mind is of the two people
that the last and final messenger of
Prophet Muhammad peace be upon him had
talked about one being a believer the
one who believes in the pure monotheism
believes in the one creator all the
prophets and all excitable comes with
their belief and then the one who just
denied a disbeliever and the believer
now having everything the disbeliever
having a mountain of money and gold and
silver and kicking it in this life right
and then the example of the believer who
went through so many hardships and tough
times and do you know which honey if I'm
talking about I got a couple of these
for you for them yeah can you go ahead
I'm just starting in often and it just
gives an example at the end this person
who Allah gave him everything because
some people perceive that this person is
so happy because he has all the material
things but he disbelieved and the other
person who had such a hard time but at
the end he gets Jenna and that person is
like did you see any hardships as like
no can you go ahead and spot me miss min
that's all I got to in mind really quick
actually make it three inch and we
conclude afterwards yes
have time insha'Allah so number one was
soleil sur la la Hollywood Sam says a
Japan the other moment the Prophet says
amazing it is the other believer not MBA
everything that amazing happens here so
prophets tell me something is amazing
and when the Prophet said something is
amazing it is what absolutely amazing
well this being said he said the
believers state is absolutely amazing
everything that happens to them is good
for them if something good happens and
they are thankful that is good for them
and I get hired and if something hard
comes upon them and they're patient that
is good for them so they you might
understand the wisdom behind that number
two but also allies on the body or senem
says the one who has been going through
all kinds of hardships rather the
probably used the exaggerated example
the one who faced the most hardship on
earth ever all that tragedy the
troublesome etc they'll be dipped in
Genda for a split of a second split of a
second night even there's a dip and come
out and definitely be asked have you
ever seen any hardship in your life you
know what the response will be I don't
know what you're talking about
for a split and the second into Jenna
that person forgot all the hardship then
the Prophet says yet to be of the one
who has been blessed with all kind of
Matusik things cars whatever it may be
money mansions fame whatever it may be
you'll be dipped in how fire one dip and
you'll be asked if you ever seen any
good in your life is it I don't know
what you're talking about
dunya is just something go it's a
snapshot very quick back and forth and
remember they're also a sign for those
had this question if Allah will not
reward for example if I lost Honda Allah
does not like the believers and the way
they disbelieve your story and the way
they were behaving
what is um uh continue to give them I'll
tell you something Allah subhana WA
Ta'ala tells us that this is the Dodge
which means a lot just dragging them the
prophets of Allah Leo Sam says whenever
someone is insisting on a sin being
advised you told don't do this don't do
that and they insist then Allah would
you can continue to give them from the
dunya don't think that this is a lot of
blessings on them the problematic is to
drive means they're dragging just like I
have a mouse in the house you have a
mouse in the house you wanna kick that
mouse away take it out or whatever if
the mouse doesn't go away what do you do
you put forward food for that mouse you
put food which which means the mouse
will stay but there's a rat trap the
mouse comes to that cheese and then when
it comes smashes it so when Allah gives
the one who insist on the sinning don't
think those are my loves them but that's
a dragging and
seven book them they get smashed we see
comes refuge from that I mean I know
asked a lot trying to allow me and you
among those who are not just dipped in
gender but stay in gender forever
highest ranks we asked also parents had
to make the brothers and sisters who are
watching us going through hardship may
Allah make them patient may Allah raise
your ranks what are we all your sins and
elevate your status and gender and
always you see Muhammad SAW Allah he was
sending the one who faced the most
hardships ever on earth barukh illogical
thank you very much we end with the
greeting that we started with the
greeting of all the prophets and
messengers peace be with you thank you
so much for now Michael well they come
sit on top and there you have it this
week's show thank you for tuning in and
we got to learn so much hopefully we can
implement it we got answers to a lot of
those questions and if anybody had any
kind of doubts hopefully God willing it
got cleared up eradicated from your mind
in this week's show we know that the
Creator Allah tells us in the Quran do
you think that you'll be left alone I'm
just saying that I believe no and that's
it no you're gonna be tested and we're
all being tested I'm being tested you're
being tested and sometimes the test is
very difficult sometimes it's easy but
we ask that the crater makes it easy and
then we can be in Jenna and we can be
successful in this life in the next and
we ask that we get rewarded for all
these trials and tests and we never give
up
that's that trust that we have to
develop that we have certainty and the
reward that's waiting for us and that we
have certainty that the Creator Allah is
merciful towards us and he doesn't wish
any harm upon us and we have to trust in
him so at the end we can have his mercy
and at the end we can have his pleasure
and at the end we can have Jenna that's
right Jenna paradise is the ultimate
goal so with that said continue to
follow us be with us here every week on
the Deen show until next time until then
peace be with you so I'm like